The Joe Rogan experience.
All right.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
so,
so you got to Utah and um,
you just,
you just wait.
Well is a lot of hiking,
you know,
you go and you essentially you go where you know that the elk are going to be in
the area and when they're in the Rut,
which is that when you hunt,
that's when it's legal,
which means they're their mating and breeding and smashing heads together.
And then you hear them,
you hear them scream at each other and you're ready to be killed.
Well,
they are definitely ready to be killed then a little do they know that?
Then you gotta figure out how to sneak in on them.
They can't help themselves.
They just,
they're competing with all these other males,
so they're always like back screaming at each other and smashing heads.
And occasionally you find one that's dead that was killed by another bowl.
But you don't eat that.
No,
no,
no.
You could,
I mean,
you certainly could if it was like a recent kill,
if you knew,
if you got to it like right when it was dying.
Yeah.
The blood was still coming out of its body,
but you will find them.
They get stabbed and they,
they kill each other.
Yeah.
I mean that's the whole reason why those antlers exists.
It's for war,
for stabbing.
They just fuck each other up.
They don't even use it to defend against other animals like wolves and shit.
They kicked the wolves most of the time.
So where do you,
how do you get the thing back?
Those things don't,
aren't light.
Yeah,
you have to,
you have to do what's called quartering it,
which is you take the legs off and you take the,
the front legs off and then you take the meat off the carcass and then you take
the heart and the liver and the edible organs and you have to pack it out.
So you have,
do you have a crew that goes with Eli or is it just you with a big ass knife?
I book,
I'm not very good at hunting.
I'm like,
if,
if hunting was a martial art,
I'd be a blue belt.
Blue Bell is like your white belt,
blue belt,
purple belt,
Brown belt,
black belt.
It's not a black belt.
I'm like a blue belt.
Maybe I could get my purple belt if I like work real hard this year.
But I go with a guide who's going to take me to the places that I need to go and
show me.
And a guy who was an experienced outdoorsman who he basically teaches you just
like having a trainer in martial arts.
Exactly.
It shows you,
yeah,
he's,
he knows the landscape is a hardened outdoorsman.
You know,
these guys never get fucking tired and they'll go and take you and show you like
it,
but then it's,
it's your job to execute the shot.
Your job to get close your job,
to stock in your job,
to make sure that you don't get what's called winded means the animal smells
you,
the wind's at your back and the wind carries your sent towards the animal.
So you have to move around a lot.
That goes into this.
A lot of thought.
Just go get the gun,
go.
Beautiful.
I don't use it.
I used to be,
oh,
which I have crazier,
but I have used a gun.
I have really?
Yeah.
I shot a bow once and it didn't go so well.
It just Kinda,
it's fun.
Boats,
just shooting targets is really fun.
It's very cathartic.
It says there's like something,
there's a release when that Arrow finds his target just feels really good.
Yeah.
It's probably some primitive shit from back when we used to rely on killing
things with those scenarios that like accuracy.
But there's something about hitting something with a,
uh,
like when you're shooting something at a target and hits it,
it's very,
very satisfying.
Rewarding.
Yeah.
And when you do that with a bow and Arrow,
it's very difficult.
It's more challenging.
It's more avoiding.
Yeah.
Never used a traditional,
but I mean,
I have like a couple of times,
but I've never really tried to shoot with like a traditional bow or the kind of
gun,
but they also got that.
No,
no,
I have you draw it.
I mean,
he would have to pull it back,
but it's a compound bow.
It relies on these mechanical,
uh,
these gears that these,
um,
what do they call cams?
He's like the bow and walking dead and we watch the one that's a crossbow.
Crossbow.
Yes.
That's a bullshit.
Oh,
then once that is a shitty gun,
okay,
so this guy's got a trigger zombies.
Now I to do that,
it would make me very angry,
very frustrated.
First of all,
he doesn't even have a broad head on that stupid thing.
He shooting him with a little pencil holes and it's killing him instantly that
that's all he,
that's all he had access to a broad head makeup brought him to break into that
break into a bass pro shop.
[inaudible] some,
you know?
Yeah man.
I actually did see a few bass pro shops in walking dead.
They just walk right past [inaudible] in their brother's dog guys nets and yeah,
gear kayaks.
Um,
so that's a crossbow.
And there's a,
that's a very controversial,
uh,
weapon amongst outdoorsmen.
Why is that?
Because they use those during a bow season.
Okay.
And is the reason why bow season like the,
if you looked at like statistics across the board,
if you have a what's called a tag,
like say if you wanted to go deer hunting you'd have to get a license and then
you'd get a tag and if the tag was available for the air,
you wanted you to pay a certain amount for that tag.
Now if you get a bow tag,
they,
they make the bow season earlier you have a higher,
much higher likelihood of failure with a bow than you do with a gun.
So I could say like 50% of the people that got a a tag,
it's usually not that high,
but if 50% of the people that got attacked for rifle were successful,
it might be 10% with a boat,
it might be even less.
It might be even less in some places,
depending on how rugged the landscape is,
how hard it is to get to where the animals are and you have to be able to shoot
far accurately.
Right.
So you do most of the shooting when you go up there.
Do you have to do all the shooting?
I shoot them myself.
Yeah.
That's a man.
That's a manly.
Asked him to do it.
Well,
you've got,
I don't do a lot of manly shit.
I noticed.
I know.
I'm probably compensating for something.
I didn't want to say that,
but yeah.